[Music]
[Applause]
China's one-child policy is regarded as
the biggest social experiment in the
human history I'm honored to be a
subject in this experiment I am one of
the 115 million only children in my
generation in 2015 when I first came to
the United States for Business School
China jobs at the one-child policy after
35 years many GSB classmates showed a
greater empathy to me saying Iran I'm so
happy for you that China eventually
dropped this evil policy how could the
Chinese government did not human rights
like that it must be really hard for you
growing up without siblings I cannot
imagine that people could not make their
own choices about how many kids to have
I really appreciated there is compassion
but deep inside I feel conflicted then
some other classmates further asked how
do you view the one-child policy
was it good or bad my response I don't
know since then I have tried to learn
more in hopes of arriving a better
answer today let me start with my own
story as the only child try to imagine
that you are a 5 year old only child
living in China like I was I have to
tell you that you have to spend some
time alone talking to yourself playing
by yourself
sometimes even hugging yourself because
you have to fly through rows in the same
time
princes and Prince but trust me
life was not that bad I had a great time
I had great companionship with my
cousins and soup and neighborhood kids
and I probably have to admit that I
cannot understand the whole concept of
siblings because all my peers are only
children as well so the ideal having
sibling never crossed my mind at home at
school we were told that the one-child
policy was fundamentally important
China to keep the population a great
size and to ensure the quality of life
at home my mom who has three other
siblings tell me a story about back in
1960s four of them had to split one loaf
of bread for a meal and all her clothes
are passed down from her to elderly
sisters
I also heard story from people of my own
age in Europe part of China where the
one-child policy had not been enforced
girls had to give away opportunities for
education for the boys at home so with
all these stories in mind I truly
believe that the one-child policy was
the right way to go for me for my family
as well as for my country until one day
in 2013 I was still working China as a
sales manager riding a bullet train from
Beijing to Shanghai I got a long message
from my mom which was very unusual she
wrote that she had been diagnosed with
the heart disease called HDD and she
needed open chest surgery as soon as
possible
she has hesitated to tell me because my
working schedules were full but she
eventually decided to let me know
because the risk of their surgery is
super high so at that moment actually I
was on a business trip with several
colleagues and also my my clients
sitting right in front of me but I burst
into tears I was terrified by the
thought what could happen to my mom I
also feel troubled how could my mom
hesitate to tell me I was her only child
I should be the person to keep company
with her take off care of her and sign
on the conscience form for the surgery
but at that moment she was still
thinking about disturbing my work this
is ridiculous so I look outside of the
train window
feel terrified helpless and as was
obligated and for the very first
the time I wished I could have a sibling
to share this fear and overcome the
hardship together so a few months later
I get back to my hometown I was very
happy to spend more time with my mom and
family members but in the meantime I was
local struggled with handling both her
work and both of her Jonas and my work
so but I'm very lucky because the
surgery was very successful and my mom
recovered however I kept thinking about
this idea of having a sibling how could
my life be different if I was not the
only child recently I send this question
to over 100 only Cal friends in China
here are some responses are really
interesting I will share with you if I
were not the only child I wouldn't be
forced to go on so many blind dates set
up by my parents however my parents
wouldn't be able to pay for the down
payments for a new apartment for me
which is as regarded as a must to get
married in China
here is one struck me most I might not
be as successful as I am because I
couldn't monopolize all the attention
and resources from my parents but I
would be more free leaving abroad
marrying to my same-sex partner instead
of living the life to meet my parents
expectations my friends are as
conflicted as I am the good is
inseparable from the bad scholars have
examined the one-child policy from many
different perspectives criticizing the
policy for violating human rights or
creating big social issues such as
little Emperor syndrome
aka China spoiler breath as a little in
program myself I am very grateful for
all the privileges I've received as an
only child
especially for the improved
opportunities for women
however I have to admit that the
excessive love and attention also
creates larger pressure after the
termination of the one-child policy I
had a conversation with my mom how many
kids do you think I should have I asked
she urged me to have a Lisa to in light
of all the downside of being the only
child but I'm not sure since I can
imagine that my future husband and I
have to support for elderly parents
adding two or more kids that's crazy and
especially given the social expectation
for taking care of the parents is way
much higher in Chinese culture and what
seems me more is the thought that if
something bad falls on me what could
happen to my mom I cannot imagine what
my mom would go through if she lost her
only child my same father is a
sociologist
specializing in the study of families
who lost their only child she told me
that now there are more than 1 million
such families in China these parents
generally are too old to give another
birth to the baby so they lost their
only hope many of suffer from tremendous
emotional trauma and recover all
hardships in terms of finance and also
life so I think this helps me to explain
part of my survey why my generation
carries a heavier by emotional burden
and is less willing to take risks with
the one-child policy good or bad to be
honest I still don't have the answer but
here is the lesson I want to share with
you were you from the outside it seems
easy to evaluate a government policy or
a business decision that had impact on
other people once you move to the inside
it's not just like snap your finger and
get to the answer to that question so I
would urge you and myself think about
the big choices and decisions on an
individual level healthy their life
stories and when you have the power to
make a decision for large group of
people no matter your political leader
or business leader try to take out the
view from the inside do not let the view
the outside dominant your choice and
this is my lesson from the one-child
policy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]